hello I was going to ask you to describe
this in terms that you would describe it
to say your daughter and then I
remembered your daughter those economics
at Cambridge yeah let's not do that
let's see let's describe this as you
could describe it to me maybe ok so
there's been a very exciting
breakthrough in the air in a field of
number theory
you know it's caused an awful lot of
excitement amongst the mathematicians as
excited as mathematicians can get and
the the crazy thing about it is that
it's come from somebody who's who's
pretty much unknown it's a guy called Yi
Tang Zhuang which is a pretty cool name
and he actually he does work at the
University of New Hampshire
it's about prime numbers the things that
certainly got me into maths in fact he
had a really struggle to get an academic
job here he worked for a time in subway
there are some amazing properties of
primes and they've led to lots of
conjectures that haven't yet been proven
there's nothing wrong working his subway
but you know normally these these are
these proves these these breakthroughs a
sort of achieved by those that are
working at Princeton Harvard these kinds
of you know really elite places and now
we've got somebody who's literally come
out of nowhere that no one expected to
produce this kind of result in it and as
and as a has done something really
impressive that many great minds were
unable to do but one in particular and
doesn't involve multiplication of primes
it involves editions of primes and it's
the fact that there seem to be an
endless series of primes which differ by
two right so we the obvious ones are the
low number Prime's or 3 & 5 & 5 & 7 11
and 13 these two prime numbers are
called twin primes okay and I called
twins because they differ by this number
two and there's a conjecture that goes
back hundreds of years which says
actually there's an infinite number of
these so the highest known pair is a
remarkable right three trillion seven
hundred and fifty six billion eight
hundred and 1 million six hundred and
ninety five thousand six hundred and
eighty five times
- ^ six hundred and sixty six thousand
six hundred and eighty nine plus one is
the higher of the pairs of primes and if
I take away one it gives me the lower of
the pairs of primes that's that's ma
it's an epic you know just to remind you
the the lower ones that we were
describing were three and five and five
and seven etc so to go to be able to do
that and show that that's a pair of
primes that differ by two is remarkable
delete it once a different way to a call
there are called twin primes
you also get of course ones that differ
by four okay these are called cousin
primes and there's even those that
differ by six and these are called sexy
primes okay so I think you've done as
well why can't you have prime numbers
that differ by seven you kind of problem
was that differ by seven yeah because
one of them will be an even number
exactly really well good yet so so we
know that there definitely are an
infinite number of prime numbers and I
can prove that for you if you want we've
done that you've done that I thought you
had okay so so you know there's an
infinite number of prime numbers what's
not people aren't sure about is that
there are an infinite number of prime
numbers that differ by two but it's
believed to be true and so the goal is
to try and show this and it's never been
shown but what has been shown for the
first time is that you can bound the
difference between two primes that day
and somebody has shown in fact Z Tang au
Tang Jiang from the University of New
Hampshire has shown that and there is a
bound between two primes let's say one
prime a and another prime B and that
bound is that you know it can be some
number N and so n would be two for the
case that we're interested in here and
that's the ultimate case that people are
interested in but what he's managed to
show is there is some number n for which
for an infinite number of
Prime's a and B this is going to be less
than or equal to 70 million okay so just
to be clear in two primes can be
separated by more than seventeen oh yes
yes yes they can
so what has shown is that and in fact
the conjecture is that there is every
single even number there is an infinite
number of primes that can be separated
by that amount so here is the even
number is two right so there's that the
conjecture is as an infinite number of
primes pairs of primes which are
separated by two but there's also a
conjecture that there's an infinite
number of pairs of prime separated by
four and an infinite number separated by
six and eight and in fact up to infinity
so they're all the even numbers that the
conjectures are there are an infinite
number of primes separated by that
amount so what he's but that no one has
been able to show that's true of any
number up to now and what he has
demonstrated is there are an infinite
number of primes which will be separated
by a number n which he hasn't yet
calculated but he knows that it's less
than 17 million there are an infinity of
these guys Oh God
hello I wave I'm in a bit of doing a
video that's well I've got ads rigged so
it starts ringing if I call you out
we're done it's in it right yeah
no the mathematicians who work on prime
numbers will now no doubt be scouring
over what he has done and I'm trying to
knock this number down I mean I was
already hearing about one of the key
people involved a guy called Goldstein
who's talked about it might be
immediately possible to knock this down
to about 16 okay and that's pretty a lot
closer to 2 than 70 million but of
course 17-minute he has a very nice way
of describing this value maybe 17
million means that the primes are not
twins but they're certainly siblings why
is why is it amazing I think it's more
the point why is it really incredible
there's a sort of nice way to illustrate
this one thing we know is that they're
obviously the
an infinite number of prime numbers but
that the gaps between the prime numbers
generically get bigger and bigger and
bigger in fact you know that the average
further for the first n good for prime
numbers between 0 and n ok the average
gap is of order log of n ok so it's just
it's just sort of it's a function but if
this is a big number
ok it's the point it's not as big as n
but it's a big number
ok so ok so let me illustrate what that
means in practice so imagine you had a
scenario where you've got all a world
with all the numbers ok and there's some
rule and I'm just going to impose this
rule because I'm king of this world and
it says that you know prime numbers can
only fall in love with all the prime
numbers ok so the idea is that you go on
dates with your nearest neighbors ok and
you know do fall in love or not ok so so
the for the prime numbers at the lower
end and you know the number spectrum
they've got it made you know three can
you know gets it on with five sevens get
on with eleven you know they don't have
to go very far before they find their
true love but when you get up to like
say a googolplex right in principle on
average you expect to go on it of order
a googol date before you're likely to
find your n you know your true love
because the prime numbers are so far
apart at that large end of things so
it's a pretty loveless place you know at
that end of thing so you get to bigger
and bigger numbers you might think
there's just no way you're going to find
your true love and you probably won't
even bother going out of house you're
just staying and watch you know Jeremy
Kyle or something but you know what what
is actually true there what what Zhang
has shown us is that for some lucky
prime numbers at that very high end of
things they actually and it's always the
case there are some that actually will
only have to go on about 70 million
dates before they they find their true
love so there are always some prime
numbers which are relatively close
together
70 million seems such an arbitrary
number yeah and it's like it how if it's
possible to explain how has that fallen
out of a broke home 3 4 5 6 ok so and so
how did help when people do number
theory how do they actually go about
doing these proofs they they tend to use
CF theory